news alert an explosion of violent crime
across the nation
raising fears ahead of the weekend in
chicago
deadly attacks surging in just the past
24 hours
four people shot and killed 28 others
wounded
including a nine-year-old girl and a
month old baby girl
both shot in the head in separate
attacks and critically wounded
this comes amid a stunning and
heartbreaking
surge of children being targeted in the
windy city the numbers just this year
showing 25 juveniles murdered in a range
of attacks
and when it comes to shootings 172
children have been shot
in just the past six months these are
just some of their faces
young lives cut short by the rise in
violence
one faith leader warning that our
children are becoming
extinct chicago alderman raymond lopez
sounding off
ahead of an emergency meeting today with
mayor lori lightfoot and the police
chief
watch the mayor is not up to the job to
keep
the city of chicago safe and we want her
on record not in a back room meeting
we want her on record to explain how
she's going to keep chicagoans safe
whereas we have seen mass shootings on
the right so we had a shooting in front
of my house
yesterday by gangbangers checking
someone who just happened to come home
with his girlfriend
it is out of control and we need to get
some results that keep people safe
joey why does it seem as if politicians
continue to fail
to appreciate to grasp the enormity
of the tragedy the magnitude of the
tragedy coming out of especially chicago
you know what surpri what really takes
me is if there was a mass shooting in
chicago tomorrow you can bet the mayor
would hold a press conference
and spend hours lecturing us on all the
reasons why it's everyone else's fault
that would be tragedy it'd be terrible
there's a tragedy of the same
size about every week there it's it's a
mass shooting one day at a time
and the mayor is where the buck stops i
think every federal law enforcement
agency in the country should have a
footprint there i think that it should
feel like there's a police on every
corner
until they figure out the root cause as
kamala would like to say
because that would appease them and
their voters but more importantly until
they stop this killing
at the end of the day the person pulling
the trigger may in fact be
a victim of a lot of things from no
parents to a bad system
but they're nowhere near more important
than the victim of the other end of that
gun
and those people are criminals and they
need to be put behind bars so that the
rest of the people in chicago have a
chance at life
and tommy the vast majority of these
homicides almost 75 percent
are young black men there in chicago are
democrats at a crossroads
democrats are certainly at a crossroads
because they need to really decide if
they want to support black lives matter
the idea or black lives matter the
organization because black lives matter
the organization
is very forthright about their goals to
defund the police so though democrats
are now trying to gaslight
and say that they are not for defunding
the police which we know is a blatant
lie
they need to be asked straight up do you
still support the organization blm
because if you do if you continue to
celebrate them to placate to them then
you support to fund the police but
furthermore
criminals know what's going on they know
not only that police departments are
being defunded
but they know that the consequences for
their actions are less they know that
they can get away with more
they're well aware that that departments
are being shorted and that recruitment
is down they know this
they also know if they do get in a
situation where they are confronted by
an officer
their go-to is to resist arrest and
maybe become the next social media
headline or the next cnn headline and
they feel that they've got largely a
pass
they know what's going on it's time for
democrats to have a day of reckoning
and decide what their priorities are
law-abiding decent americans
or thugs felons in the blm organization
choice is simple
and harris the chicago mayor lightfoot
has called the
reporting on these heartbreaking murders
the legitimate public
outcry at the extinction of children
there as quote
racist and sexist yeah i mean those
are the new jump boards right i mean you
you just jump right off the pier and and
drag everybody with you into the water
if you get called one of those names
and she knows that she knows that then
suddenly the conversation is over when
you call somebody racist
uh it doesn't solve any of her problems
though last hour i had
uh former congress former congresswoman
maya rockingmore cummings
also the widow of the civil rights icon
elijah cummings on and i said
specifically
this is black on black crime in most
instances we're not talking about cops
white cops killing black men you gave
that statistic of the percentage of
the people who were dying in the streets
of chicago you're spot on emily and i
said so where's the peaceful protest
where are the people in the streets she
punted on that question i gave her
extra time she didn't answer it and when
i called her on it she said
oh well i'm happy to get into that and i
said yeah but i gave you a shot i'm not
going to let her talk
over my other guest matt schlapp's time
like that's not fair you had your shot
i'll come back to you
so so that's where we are it's an
ostrich syndrome
don't want to look at it don't want to
hold others accountable who could change
it
by looking at it it's like they're lost
or manipulative because if you don't say
it then it can't be misquoted and lord
knows you don't want to tick off the far
left if you are in politics and kaylee
horrifyingly this trend
this sustained murder of our children is
not new
yeah i mean stop and think about that
quote that you read in your introduction
our children are becoming extinct think
about how
heartbreaking that is i want to put up a
cover that has haunted me ever since i
saw it it's from last july of the new
york post
i'll never forget seeing this this was
deval gardner he was one
year old at a barbecue when he lost his
life
and that is his casket there and you see
it's um colorful the cocoa melon it's
it's a cartoon that my daughter watches
um but this little boy my daughter was
nine months old
this little boy one years old lost his
life at a barbecue
and his dad said this it just hurts my
son is gone i don't have nobody i don't
have somebody to call me
daddy daddy daddy these are human
lives where is the children's lives
matter
i want that organization to start
because this has been happening for more
than a year
and blaming this on racism negative
coverage and
calling me a karen as uh mayor lori
lightfoot did that doesn't solve
problems
let's come together right and left
because i don't want to see another
casket
like that of deval gardner joey
final thoughts yeah
i i think it i don't understand why um
there are excuses and not compassion and
just absolutely a fire to act on this i
don't understand
you know when you blame the gun really
what we're learning is what you're
trying to do is protect the culprit
and so there's this whole movement of
empathy towards those
who find themselves in a position that
they need to turn to crime
and i understand that but not to the
detriment of innocent people who don't
make that decision
and that's what really bothers me it's
all about gun policy and take guns off
the streets
if the gun is bad then the person
pulling the trigger is is sure sell evil
and that's really should be our
perspective